Gregor Mendel’s experiments laid the foundation
of modern day Genetics.
We have seen so far that Mendel crossed a
purple flowered plant with a white flowered
plant.
He then collected the seeds and grew new plants
from them.
Astonishingly, he found that all the offsprings
had purple coloured flowers.
Now, on crossing these plants among themselves,
Mendel surprisingly obtained three purple
flowered plants and one white flowered plant.
How could this be possible?
Moreover, what could be the probable reasons for this?
The first set of results were that all the
plants in the first or F one generation were
with purple coloured flowers.
Here, the term “F1” indicates the FIRST
FILIAL generation.
In this case, he considered Colour of the
flower as a character.
Did he cross pea plants having other characters too?
Yes! he considered ALL the other characters
like plant height, seed colour and so on.
And then he found that only ONE character
is expressed in the F1 generation.
For instance, he crossed a pea plant having
round seeds with the one having wrinkled seeds.
In the F1 generation, he obtained all the
plants having ONLY ROUND seeds.
It implied that the offsprings are similar
to ONLY ONE of the parents and do not have
any resemblance with the other ! And this
was seen for all the characters!
Now getting back to our example of flower colour…
Mendel obtained all the plants with purple
coloured flowers in the F1 generation.
But this wasn’t the case in the next step
When the offsprings from this F1 generation
were crossed, one plant out of the four had
traits just like the original parent that
was considered.
That means in this case, one out of the four
had white coloured flowers and three had purple
coloured flowers.
With this, he concluded that characters are
passed from one generation to the other.
With the current knowledge we have, we know
that this is due to the passing of genes.
However, it was not known back then.
Mendel named these as “factors”.
So it was believed that there are “factors”
which carry these traits from one generation
to the other.
But what about the disappearance of the trait
in one complete generation?
In the F1 generation, the trait of white coloured
flowers was not seen at all.
This was explained by Mendel in a very efficient manner.
He explained that in organisms like the green
peas, one “FACTOR ” is always expressed
and it super powers the presence of the OTHER “factor”.
We call these factors as “genes” or “alleles” now.
We will have a detailed look at what genes
mean in our upcoming parts.
But,for now, let us focus on Mendel’s work.
In today’s terms, Mendel said that some
genes are always expressed irrespective of
the other.
These are called Dominant genes . The others
which are suppressed are referred to as recessive
genes .
So why did the recessive genes not express
themselves in the F1 generation?
And how did they get expressed in the F2 generation?
Let's understand this with the help of a
theoretical explanation of this cross.
Let's consider letter “P” written in
upper case as the allele, that is “factor”
in Mendel’s terms, for the purple coloured flower.
And the white coloured flower will be represented
with the allele “p” written in lower case.
Now, the first cross included purple flowered
plant and a white flowered plant.
So this is how we can represent this crossing.
Any idea why have we used the letter “P” twice here?
It’s simple!
The Green pea plant is a diploid plant.
What does “diploid” mean?
We have always come across the saying that
humans have “23 PAIRS” of chromosomes…
That’s because the chromosomes in us are
always in pairs.
Each set has one chromosome from each parent.
This is nothing but the diploid nature.
So when organisms have two sets of chromosomes,
they are referred to as “diploid” organisms.
Getting back to green peas, there are two
sets of genes in it.
That is why we use the letter twice to represent
both the allelic forms.
So here, “PP” written in upper case will
represent the purple colour of flowers, while
“pp” written in lower case will represent
the white colour of flowers!
Now in this cross, the gametes, which are
nothing but the reproductive cells, will be
formed like this… and the cross will yield
us this result.
How?
This combination, this one, then this one
and this is the last one!
These are the 4 possible combinations.
Now, as you can see here, “Pp” indicates
that the offspring has one dominant and one
recessive allele.
In such a case, the plants will have only
purple flowers, as the presence of one dominant
gene is enough to express the trait.
That is the reason why ALL the plants have
purple coloured flowers in the F1 generation.
Now, can you guess why the ratio “three
to one” is obtained in the F2 generation?
Let's find that out with the help of a similar
theoretical cross.
Here, we take any two random plants from the
F1 generation.
Crossing these two or even by carrying out
the selfing process in a similar fashion gives
us this result.
Now, as we can see here, these three offsprings
have at least one dominant gene.
That is the reason why each of these is a
purple flowered plant.
Now in this case, both the genes are recessive:
that means no gene to dominate the trait.
As a result, the plant expresses the recessive
trait that is white coloured flowers.
This was the simplest way to explain Mendel’s results.
Dominant genes are those which are expressed
in both: homozygous and heterozygous forms.
On the other hand, recessive genes are those
which can be expressed only when present in
homozygous form.
Hold on…
Any idea, what we mean by Homozygous and
Heterozygous?
We know that the term “homo ” means same
and “hetero ” means different.
So Homozygous means the set of genes are same
: both either dominant or both recessive.
For example, “PP” and “pp” are both
homozygous forms.
Heterozygous is exactly opposite of this!
It simply means both the forms are different.
So here, “Pp” represents the heterozygous
form: one dominant and one recessive!
So, the dominant alleles are expressed in
both homozygous and heterozygous forms, while
recessive alleles can be expressed when present
only in the homozygous forms!
This was just an introduction to Mendel’s experiments.
Let's have a look at one more example and
a few more terms in genetics in the next part!
We have seen how the cross of a character
like flower colour is carried out.
In this part, let's get introduced to a few
more interesting terms in genetics.
But, before that, let's understand the cross
of one more character and get thorough with
it!
Before beginning any such experiment, we need
to make sure that the parents selected are
Homozygous in nature.
So let’s say, we wish to cross two organisms
with some trait named “A”.
The dominant form should ideally be “AA”
both in upper case, while the recessive form
has to be “aa” both in lower case.
Now, the recessive form will definitely be homozygous.
Why?
Yes, we know that the recessive character
is expressed only when it is in the homozygous
form.
But the dominant character can have both the
set of alleles.
So, “AA” in upper case as well as “Aa”
one in upper and the other in lower case,
can give us a dominant case.
So, it could be homozygous or heterozygous.
Now, how are we supposed to know whether the
organism considered for crossing is homozygous
or heterozygous for a particular character?
For this, we have the concept of pure lines
Pure lines are nothing but the descendants
obtained after inbreeding for several generations
Confused? Don’t be!
It’s easy to understand this with an example.
Let’s say we have this particular breed
of dogs.
Both these have genes for a good coat on their
skin, say “C”.
So, both these dogs may have the genes “CC”
both in upper case or “Cc” that is, one
in upper and the other in lower case.
On crossing these two dogs, we get these offsprings.
Clearly, the genes are passed to this generation.
Now, on crossing any of the two dogs from
this same progeny, we get these offsprings.
That means again, the same set of genes is
passed to the next generation.
Imagine, this is done for a few more generations.
What will be the result?
The progeny at the end will have these genes
conserved.
But notice something interesting!
As we keep crossing the individuals in the
same family, the chances of obtaining the
homozygous form is enhanced.
This process of crossing individuals from
the same family is called inbreeding . And
offsprings obtained after inbreeding several
generations are called pure lines .
One of the advantages of using pure lines
while beginning the experiment is to have
an assurance that the organism is HOMOZYGOUS
even for the dominant trait.
Now, let's focus back on the cross we were
about to carry out!
This time, let's consider the character “Stem
Height ” in the pea plant.
Here, we take a tall and a dwarf plant.
Both these are pure lines.
On crossing the Parental generation, we get
these offsprings in the F1 generation.
Now, what will happen when we cross these
two plants from the F1 generation?
It will give us these results.
Take a moment to go through this.
So what we get is three tall plants and one dwarf plant.
Isn’t this the same ratio that Mendel obtained
when flower colour was considered as the character?
Yes it is!
He had obtained three purple and one white
flower in the F2 generation.
Similarly, here we get three tall and one dwarf plant!
Now that we have had a good idea about crossing,
let me introduce 2 new terms to you…
Trust me they are very simple to understand!
The two terms are phenotypic ratio and genotypic ratio!
In this case , the phenotypic ratio is three to one.
That is three tall plants and one dwarf plant!
And the genotypic ratio is one to two to one.
As we can see, one plant is homozygous for
the tall trait, these two are heterozygous
and this one is homozygous for the recessive
trait, dwarf!
Any idea, what these terms mean?
Let's understand them first and then proceed
with understanding the ratios!
The features that can be seen or observed
by us externally are called “phenotypes”.
Pheno is a prefix that indicates an OBSERVABLE
characteristic!
We could clearly see in this case, three are
tall and one is a dwarf plant.
Hence, the phenotypic ratio is three to one.
What about the genotypic ratio?
Let’s take an example here!
If we look at this tall guy, what can we say
about his genes?
This tall guy can have the genes ‘TT’
both in uppercase, or ‘Tt’ one in upper
and the other in lower case!
We can’t really predict it!
So just by having a GLANCE, we can’t really
guess if the individual is homozygous or heterozygous
for height as the character.
So the features at the genetic level, which
cannot be observed, are called “genotypes
”.
In simple words, the physical expression of
the genes, giving rise to the particular observable
traits can be termed as “phenotype”.
On the other hand, genotype can be defined
as the set of genes that give rise to a particular
trait : That is the genetic makeup of an organism!
So, the trait that's visible to us is the
phenotype and what genes the organism has
for that trait, is the genotype.
For example, if this boy has black eyes, then
the eye colour seen by us is the boy’s phenotype,
and the genes that he has inherited from his
parents, which are not seen by us are a part
of his genotype!
Now getting back to our experiment…
How do we understand the genotypic ratio?
Well, as we can see, we have one homozygous
tall plant, two heterozygous tall plants,
and one homozygous dwarf plant.
So, the genotypic ratio is one to two to one.
Now, we are well versed with the crosses and
also a few important terms in genetics.
Take a moment to go through these important
terms once!
Let's now move ahead and understand Gregor
Mendel’s experiments further.
So far, we have seen how Mendel crossed plants
and studied one character at a time . Do you
think he always crossed only a single character
at a time?
No
After he completed crossing all the characters
individually, he crossed two characters at
a time, followed by three and so on!
The cross involving one character at a time
is called Monohybrid cross . So, whatever
we have learnt so far was a Monohybrid cross.
And the ratio obtained after the cross is
nothing but a Monohybrid ratio.
How is a Dihybrid cross that is a cross involving
two characters at a time carried out then?
And what about the Dihybrid ratio?
Let's get to know that in the next part!